with nearly four billion dollars in
worldwide grosses and Counting the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is clearly
doing something right but it's still
always tempting to imagine what might
have been if directors had chosen to do
things a little differently let's do a
heroic double tape with these Marvel
movie alternate endings you might not
know about 1998's Blade the version of
blade that made it to theaters enter
their hero slaying a bunch of vampire
minions before settling in for a
long-awaited battle versus the movie's
big bad guy Deacon Frost
Blade vanquishes frost once and for all
with an overdose of anti-vampire poison
which he delivers by kicking a syringe
right into Frost's forehead making him
blow up kind of cheesy but it works
unlike the unused alternate ending which
would have shown frost achieving his
goal of becoming the blood god and
morphing into a whirling fountain of
blood that still somehow has Frost's
face in it the sequence would be pretty
dumb even with today's effects
technology so you can imagine how bad it
would have looked at the digital effects
available during the 90s thankfully we
were spared in the final cut
2010's Iron Man 2 the Iron Man sequel
gave Tony Stark a pair of bad guys to
contend with mad scientist Ivan Vanko
and Justin Hammer a business rival who
partners with Lanka to steal the Iron
Man technology
unfortunately for hammer Bunco aka the
villainous whiplash has a few screws
loose and he isn't above double-crossing
his partner to achieve his ultimate goal
of revenge against Tony
Blanco ultimately ends up dead and
Hammer goes to jail but in the alternate
ending Bunco meets his maker a little
differently blasted to bits in the last
minute after kidnapping Pepper Potts
2013's The Wolverine Wolverine from 2013
mark Hugh Jackman 6 outing as the iconic
Marvel neutral but none of them gave him
an opportunity to wear his classic comic
book costumes director James Mangold
looked to fix this problem in his movie
though it still hit the cutting room
floor in the end in the theatrical cut
the film closes with Wolverine boarding
a jet heading back to rejoin the x-men
but Mangold's unused ending also
includes a glimpse of his bodyguard
Yukio presenting him with a box
containing his iconic opera from the
comics you should have warned in Days of
Future past but 2015's ant-man observant
viewers may have noticed that ant-man
left a big loose end untied after trying
to purchase yellow jackets eyes altering
technology Hydra agent Mitchell Carson
ultimately ends up getting
with attack during movies final battle
originally director Peyton Reed meant to
finish his film by having ant-man face
off against Carson but the crossover
demands of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
dictated a teaser prelude for Captain
America Civil War so that's a battle
that will have to wait for another day
perhaps during the sequel 2013's Iron
Man 3 in the original ending iron man's
foe the Mandarin actually an actor named
Trevor Slattery hired to distract our
hero
is hauled off to prison for his part in
aiding elder Killians evil schemes
that's a far kinder fate than the one he
suffers in the earlier version of the
script and which Slattery uses the
unstable extremis to / Soldier Serum and
like many of the other poor Schmucks who
used it he goes out with a bang
thankfully they were smart and kept him
around so they can do that awesome short
with him 2009 s x-men origins Wolverine
for many Marvel fans one of the most
disappointing parts about x-men origins
Wolverine was what the movie did with
Deadpool in origins the Merc with mouth
is reduced to a pale mute shadow of his
comic book south director Devin hood
through the characters fans of bone with
one of several post-credit scenes
attached to different prints of the
movie one sequence shows a hand emerging
from rubble and reaching out to touch
Deadpool severed head after which his
eyes open he chooses at the camera maybe
he was trying to tell the audience not
to ask for refunds 2014's the amazing
spider-man 2 comic readers know that
spider-man has been through a lot of
changes over the years some more bizarre
than others he's always been an orphan
with the death of his parents partially
driving him to play the hero after he
was bit by a radioactive spider but in a
deleted ending to 2014's the amazing
spider-man 2 Peter's father Richard
reveals himself to be very much alive
even offers a variation on spider-man's
iconic motto with great power comes
great responsibility
2006 his x-men The Last Stand widely
regarded as the worst entry in the x-men
series 2006 is the last stand made a
number of unpopular decisions like
killing off a bunch of beloved
characters that took a saw franchise
reboot to untangle even though a series
of alternate endings were filmed for
last and none of them would have made
the movie much better so it's easy to
understand why glimpses of Beast
returning to help run Xavier school
while returning to VCAT alien powers
return and Wolverine going back to
Canada all ended up on the cutting room
floor
we still need Professor X to mind wipe
our memories of the juggernaut 2015's
Avengers the age of Ultron with the
biggest cast in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe the Avengers franchise has more
options than most when it comes to
alternate endings director Joss Whedon
took full advantage of this with 2015's
age of Ultron he briefly entertained the
notion of working spider-man into the
story an option nixed by the studio who
still didn't have the rights to the
character during filmmaking Whedon also
considered showing audiences a glimpse
of Captain Marvel in the final scene
another idea Marvel Studios denied since
the character hadn't yet been cast for
her own standalone feature finally the
director thought about revealing that
the slain Quicksilver was alive after
seemingly being gunned down during the
movie's climactic fight however we can
correctly realized that this would have
cheapen the character's death earlier in
the movie still we wish we could have
seen all the Avengers Assemble thanks
for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to see
more videos like the one you just saw